la Réunion m'a inspirée la femme
inspirée c'est ainsi que Géraldine Gabin
évoque sa participation au concours
Célimène un peu de hasard mais avant
tout un tableau créé en trois jours
barzot et ça signifie Aurore en créole
et c'est ce que j'ai voulu exprimer
c'était l'horreur les premiers jours la
naissance du peuple réunionnais et c'est
pour ça que dans ce tableau le fond est
fait de collage de vieux articles de
journaux qui traitent de la du
peuplement de la réunion des articles de
journaux chinois des vieux livre tamouls
et pour justement donc représenter toute
tout le métissage du peuple réunionnais
avec l'esclave marron ici pour les
origines également et puis la maman
aussi la maman qui est aux origines de
la vie et puis voilà le portrait de la
petite cave au centre le début de la vie
la naissance de la Réunion un tableau
composé de plusieurs matières et cette
matière les membres du jury y trouve le
reflet d'une histoire unique j'ai
participé je suis quand même partie au
Maroc je me suis dit je l'aurais pas le
prix c'est juste le plaisir de
participer et puis j'étais tellement
contente déjà d'avoir pu vous faire un
tableau c'était voilà et de participer
et donc je n'étais pas là et je l'ai
appris que 15 jours après quand je suis
rentrée un voyage un de plus mais le
retour et cette récompense c'est une
immense joie pour Géraldine et voilà
beaucoup de fierté une grande surprise
et puis ouais vraiment la fierté et puis
un bel encouragement un bel
encouragement en continu parce que je
débutais dans la peinture et donc voilà
ça m'a fait très plaisir le prix c'est
l'hymen cet enseignante en français
ivoine néanmoins un signe elle veut
explorer plus avant les techniques de
peinture à prendre davantage et à
libérer parce que du coup je me dis j'ai
peut-être quelque chose et donc je vais
essayer de m'exprimer davantage avec le
support plastique un encouragement qui
l'amène à faire des expos en 2013 il n'y
en aura quatre on commence à exposer
j'ai fait quatre expositions cette année
et ça a plutôt bien marché il y a un bon
accueille du public et donc voilà je
continue j'essaie de progresser de
diversifier mes techniques et puis il y
a les voyages la Birmanie le Népal
Madagascar et ses carnets de voyage donc
certains croquis deviennent des tableaux
c'est l'inspiration de ce que je fais je
peins des gens que je rencontre en
voyage
tous mes supports papier ce sont des des
papiers artisanaux des vieux livres que
je ramène de mes voyages donc ça nourrit
vraiment mes tableaux donc voyager
peindre et exprimer comme ça les
rencontres que je fais lors des voyages
les émotions que je ressens et c'est de
les faire passer à travers un tableau
c'est recouvert avec un tissu
traditionnel du Népal puisque c'est un
carnet de voyage sur le Népal des
carnets de voyage qu'elle conçoit aussi
dans le cadre scolaire avec ses élèves
une autre manière d'aborder l'écriture
l'expression des sensations des émotions
et surtout une belle manière de se
souvenir de ces visages rencontrés au
détour d'un chemin à l'autre bout du
monde l'ombre de Célimène est sans doute
pas loin